hey thank you within a service and the
terrible Kelly okie concert finally over
it's time to get the chef and the
management together and find out what an
earth is going on here let's get one
thing
absolute certain it is not a taste of
Tuscany it's not funny
so plus the fun
so are you are you are you proud of this
because I'm not allowed to change
anything
oh my god I feel like there is many
pricing issues here there definitely
change that hat that you're amazing
it's just total [ __ ] it's just total
[ __ ] you know it's just like lying
no we work within the constraints and
I'm allowed to organize my you have done
nothing since you came in here but talk
about me behind my back try to set me up
to fail every [ __ ] day why do I want
to make you look I don't know I wish the
hell I did know but I've got several
people we can line up and we'll tell
them exactly what you imagine we will
only thing you'll say the party words
not to me is I hope he hangs himself
it's about as horrible as when somebody
hires all new people intel teaches every
one of them that she's a [ __ ] to work
for you can't work her either but hang
in there because it's six months I'll be
running this place and she'll be gone I
mean literally right on the box right
out of the box
there you go goes back to yeah because
that's when I found out what an
untrustworthy backstabbing son of a
[ __ ] you are I got to worry about my
back continuously with you what's this
major miracle man that was supposed to
come in here and double and triple this
business when there's been no change
whatsoever none well you wanted to hire
new people what you did location every
one of them that they shouldn't work for
me go on site is that true
there was the impression given that Cali
would no longer be here why were you
suggesting that she's not going to be
here after Sierra starts I don't recall
it everybody does the general manager
badmouth the owner behind her back yes
cool she doesn't trust if you can about
Malcolm arches about if you were the
owner what would you do I would fire
that person that badmouth me
you're fired
I think I'm leaving I was just fired Oh
cally I'm sorry you've already failed
and you need a fall guy okay you got me
you run it you step up to the plate good
luck
I'm leaving too I'm out of here I feel
betrayed and if the [ __ ] thinks I'm
gonna stay she's nuts do you know I
don't mind cally yelling at me it's fine
she finally got it off her [ __ ] chest
but she doesn't trust anybody
you know everybody's burned her in her
history I don't know I didn't burn it it
felt good to fire him because it's been
a cancer here at the hotel so now the
tumors been cut out and we're gonna be
in better shape